321 hallo ich in meine lieben freunde
und herzlich willkommen zu einer folge
nicht hunger games sondern mindset das
ist ein abklatsch von der days at what
auf einem server hier also dich mit der
model sondern auf einem server und
zusammen dabei ist der typ zu dem ich
hatte im laufe der hier bist du okay
minecraft experte ach hallo tim jawoll
kommst du adventisten tour überhaupt
spaß als wir haben uns hier wir sind auf
seinem server die seite wo die ganzen
server stehen ist glaube ich mein set
punkt net oder irgendwie so na also
daher haben wir glaube ich den server
jetzt ins länder manhattans kind von
einem slider man gar nicht so an sich
einfach gar keine einfach so nach dem
motto hey was macht denn na ja gut wir
haben uns ja alle schon durchgelesen und
da sind sachen dabei also unser
experience level unten ist zum beispiel
wie durstig wir sind und mit äxten
können wir zombies in einer großen
gruppe schlagen und es gibt mir halt
auch zombies die sind schneller
überlegen besser und es ist halt einfach
wie minecraft wie days at nur mit
minecraft blöcken quasi und um hier zu
sparen es einfach mein set spawn
eingeben also ich bin schon drin hier
gerade nachts das natürlich sehr gut
wo bist du ich sehe ja gleich aber wie
schon woanders glaube ich wir sollten
auch dazu sagen dass wir beide total
look sind also weekend das ziemlich gar
nicht und müssen uns jetzt erstmal hier
einfinden
wer mich angreift ich habe dennoch
gezeigt dass sich freundlich bin wo bist
du genau welche koordinaten moment nicht
aufgepasst am tiefen weg ich kann auch
nicht gucken und man sollte er nicht
laufen sonst oder das radio wachse das
wieder zombies du schon längst ihre
gewalt
ich glaube das wird nicht ich lasse mich
erst mal umbringen wenn die server haken
aber ein bisschen dem grab durchlassen
erst mal bringen uns sondern auch noch
mal das habt ihr gerade ein wenig mio
möchtet ihr immer reagieren den sound
ein bisschen leiser wobei mir hat gerade
disconnect besser muss ich warten ja
eigentlich also ja das steht
wahrscheinlich 30
ja ich schau mal wo warst du was für ein
gebiet in stara zwölf sekunden auf ich
war bei so einer brücke beim gras also
wie ihr seht wir sind echt total cups
könnte auch in die kommentare schreiben
wenn ihr wollt dass er einfach total
schlecht sind also dafür müssen wir uns
erstmal sofort entschuldigen also ich
bin schlecht tennis natürlich profi
welche dimension nicht einmal angeguckt
und ich fange hat aus der welt raus ist
es auch ganz gut an jetzt folgt kate
middleton so aufgeregt ich bin einem
sumpfgebiet merten koordinaten sentix -
30 hey das ist schon mal weg - 2900 sehe
ich gerade das neue - 2900 und z500 gut
dann komm mal was sind deine experte
dass ich einfach mal 10 meter treffen
also ich komme zu ungefähr einrichtungen
ich bin bei xp - 2206 - 2200 oder sind
es rund 2200 ja muss ich dieses meer
schwimmen 200 punkten
ja gut da müsste da hinten im hof
estland sein
ich denke immer man kann auf jeden fall
durch durchs land gehen oder diverser
das liegt nicht so aus als ob senden
weiter geht bin ich sicher bis offenbach
schon mal kurz in dieser komischen liste
berichtet überall zeichen mit doch da
besser nc expert.de gesehen die gesehen
haben wie zombie zombie gesehen
erkenntnissen dorf ein dorf ich hoffe
jetzt einfach hier an der küste machte
auch ein bisschen die getötet der die
trappen richtig viele sachen fällt mir
darauf was denn der hat letter to pick
rotten flesh paper lothar bott jemand
das ist
ich habe jetzt water buttle 17 also bei
diesem experiment nissen spieler du ich
hab meine frage ich hab rotter dieses
experience ding auf 17
muss ich da etwas trinken unbedingt also
letztendlich aber ich denke mal dass man
ruhig ein bisschen weniger haben kann
also man sollte es nicht um die
verschwenden ich voll oder du hast es
trinken und wenn du dann eine mehr bist
oder sogar um das auffüllen versuche ja
das geht ja ich bin sogar mehr
welche fragen das dann irgendwie
durchgängig saufen ist ein zombie ich
versuche jetzt irgendwie an ihm vorbei
zu schauen wir mal der treter immer
seine komischen runden
okay okay okay ich bin an ihm vorbei das
ist gut läuft ja der kuschel an du ich
bin gab es im komischen dorf aber das
liegt auf dem weg läuft man einfach mal
entgegen
trulla das video zu können unvergessen
ist
nein er hat mich gesehen also der zombie
und nicht auf wenn ich das gleich noch
ein spieler von hinten kommt los angeles
porto das zweite das habe ich auch
gesagt die koordinaten dann habe ich
nicht gehört ich nicht ich glaube ja
sogar zu denen - 2900 bin ich gerade und
z 300 dann muss man bei ist mir
irgendwie toll oder an der küste lang
und das wort hier so ein bogen oder ob
man muss nicht komplett durch mehr man
kann auch man kann auch normal den weg
gehen oder ist ein zombie der ich blute
wieso hat er mich dann wieder anvisiert
was also wenn man mich weißt du wie das
ist mit dem guten hier ja ich glaub man
braucht viel schnee
ich hab ich auch aber ich weiß nicht wie
man sieht dass man blutet keine ahnung
wieso er weißt du dass du blut ist
überhaupt ich habe schon bekommen und
dann stand da das ich blute ehrlich
könnt ihr das so einstellen auf dem
server ich würde so teleportiert
irgendwie eine komische art und weise
wir sind auf jeden fall ziemlich viel
interessanter ob eine kiste mit
eingebunden schwert schönbrunn auf höfen
kann man nicht zugreifen noch kisten
also ich komme jetzt mal wieder in deine
richtung laufen gott irgendwie voll ihr
weg in die city zum stream stark
direkt vor allem von am verrecken hier
oder sind spieler bitte sehe mich nicht
ich finde es ist voll schwer sich zu
heilen weil man hatte nur diese diese
papiere
das ist als bandagen umsonst auf ein
schlecht und man findet auch kaum was
irgendwie bei mir ist das problem ich
habe wenig herzen
ich weiß nicht wie ich die heide weil
ich hab komplettes futter denen es keine
ordnung die herzliche nicht von selber
bitte in die kommentare schreiben werde
das ist so dass hier wieder wasser
auffüllen trinken bitte greifen nicht an
bestimmte personen die da oben ist ja
beste equipment gibt es im norden wo ist
denn hier der norden von hier aus was
erst norden oder süden herrscht also
steht hier erneut okay bei daisy weiß
ich dass es eigentlich im süden ist ich
meine aus videos zu kennen dass es auch
im neuen war er lieber wie gesagt ich
habe das nie gespielt wenn immer als ich
gespielt weil sie einfach nicht lang
gespielt aber ich hab halt das spiel und
dort ist es eigentlich so dass im süden
so die größten städte sind sondern
vielleicht sind die städte ja erst mal
dafür da sich dann so bisschen
auszurüsten und den norden standen auch
sein
spannende oder so ok wat sag mal genau
deine koordinaten jetzt - 2500 und - 359
versuchen arbeitszeit erstmal auf null
zu kommen läuft dann in meine richtung
glaube ich jetzt zurück wenn ich dann in
richtung 2009 - 2900 gehen will damals
bei ex - 2008 - 2800 und bei z 0
ok ich versuche durch müsste irgendwo zu
sein
ich glaube das ist ein sumpfgebiet hier
ja das ist ein ziemlich langes
sumpfgebiet hier auf jeden fall hier
sind aber auch keine kästen oder so und
ich man kann es auch nicht abbauen oder
ich glaube nicht also ich sehe nur
wasser in der richtung ich gemein
das ging gleichwohl neben mir
mai - 2010 bei - 2800 bin ich jetzt bei
null bin ich jetzt auch schon traurig
sie wollte zum biest ja und ich schrieb
laufen hinterher aber ich weiß nicht
warum bist du denn schon einem
sumpfgebiet ach man braucht ganz viele
papiere damit man sich wieder heilen
kann aber man müsste jetzt seine
kollegen fest
dann komme ich ein bisschen entgegen und
ich hätte mich jetzt ins wasser - 2660
und und - 250
aber ich glaube jetzt wieder in richtung
z 0 macht das dann komme ich da entgegen
oder schnee heft das hier schnee das ist
wirklich sehr stolz darüber schwimmen
soll jedoch nicht doch nicht nur einen
kleinen graf fehler
achtung wer ist wahrscheinlich in seinem
du bist wahrscheinlich im tannenwald
gebiet erteilung oder wasser steht also
so sieht das hier aus ich bin jetzt bei
- 2600 - 50 das sieht schon gedroht dass
stehen müssten
ja ich sage ich stehe am rand von der
insel werde ich bei der winter ja ich
bin ich bin was ich bin im wasser hier
ich sage ich ja ja ja
wasser wasser hier ist was hinter dir
aber der hat hier sein schwert gezeigt
und geblockt sind das zeichen dass die
nichts von einem wollen
er will nichts von uns hat es aber
schade weil wir einfach mal töten so
ganz und wer also ich hab ihn nur noch
viereinhalb herzen und erich 1 und 4 1
über dinge
was ich will erstmal wieder
wasserflaschen auf gebt mir trinken
kaffee als 20 geht nicht oder
wir brauchen auf jeden fall irgendwie
ich brauch papier für mich zu wenden
ich habe ein papier noch herrlich fische
leben hast du danke 444 glaube ich und
ich und ich habe noch ein halbes hunger
ding ja davon habe ich sechseinhalb aber
da braucht man irgendwie wie fleisch
oder so etwas war was kann man denn hier
noch suchen
ich glaube jetzt nicht so die landschaft
ich nochmal eigentlich nur kisten finden
und das ist das verstehe ich nicht weil
ich finde nicht ist
ich hab da muss man nicht mehr sagen
können oder es geht um welche tricks
es gibt eine metapher sehr interessant
das ist ja hier gebaut so ich will ihr
leben kann man auch komplett sterben ja
wenn ich jetzt sterben also ich glaube
schon wenn ich jetzt sterben da werde
ich übrigens in zombie und plötzlich an
als appell ich ja auch komponieren auf
interesse deswegen will ich aufpassen
wie von alleine oder also ich dachte
steuer stehen
ich habe getötet habe jetzt ganz viele
tolle sachen mitgenommen dann komme ich
jetzt wieder und versucht zuletzt kommen
würde ich sagen er sekunden
ich höre von ihnen wo schritte es ist
gar nicht gut tue
es hält sich derbe so an als ob irgendwo
in einer neben mehr wert weil die
schritte in meinem headset kommt
irgendwie von rechts ist es gar nicht
toll aber steckt fest wo bist du einmal
eine toll so ich bin jetzt bei minus 300
brauchst du scheiße 300 weg kannst du
dich nicht irgendwie umbringen nochmals
braun konnte ich auch müsste doch
machbar sein weil du müsstest schon
irgendwas vierstelliges bauen weil sonst
ist das doof und ich sehe auch irgendwie
keine kisten oder so ich laufe hier rum
und oberstdorf daisendorf teil nicht
mehr zurück teleportiert ich auch bernie
findet es nicht lustig dass ich meine
eigenen leichen fast geschafft haben
okay gut in dem dorf ist keiner versteht
aufnehmen
ich war schwer so schritte paranoia
spieler
ich glaube in dem dorf ist keiner wo
bist du jetzt das angebot ähnlich jack
warner hatten sein gebiet sagt mit 60 -
500 würden ihren typ angreifen 500 und
dann 500 - 500 + 4
okay wenn ich sage lasst die normalen
bringen wir es wahrscheinlich zu viel
verlangt und ich habe angst ist eine axt
besser als ein holzschwert eisenach
dessen was in eisenachs besser als ein
holzschwert ja ich schon
ich habe richtig angst habe ich glaube
ich bin gleich auch tot und dann kann
ich ja mal zu dir kommen weil ich hab
euch jetzt übrigens richtig getötet dass
er deswegen kann ich ja dann zu dir
kommen da gibt es leider zu stark ist
mir gar nicht trifft irgendwie ja auch
schon aufgefallen oder du versuchst
einfach mal dich zu töten und irgendwo
bei einem vierstelligen iks koordinaten
punkt wo ich dicke hose gut so schnell
tot
lasst mich in ruhe zombies ist ein
spieler jetzt getötet ja ein areal eine
fiese so jetzt töten das geld ausgeht
4000 millionen 4000 sein ansporn
irgendwo neu er musste ja okay gut diese
dieses große haus wer sich in diese
windmühle die verdächtig cool danach aus
ist endlich alter ist das dorf groß
fällt mir darauf dass eine richtige
stadt hier aber hier drin das ist so
dunkel hundertprozentig in der falle
oder zombies oder so ich brauche einfach
nur ruhig wie vor zurück der partie weiß
nicht warum behagt das ganz schön hier
koordinaten jetzt ja ich bin bei minus
2409 460 wie das web plus 2800 aber
jetzt tue ich mich wirklich
das ist so dunkel hier ist ungefähr
auswahl geht glaube ich auch aber da
muss er wieder warten ich kann mir
danach da nie im leben hochlaufen dunkel
und werde ich dann wieder wenn der lobby
gesponnen oder da wo ich vorher war in
der lobby glaube ich dass wir temporär
gespeichert ich weiß es nicht
bis das erste mal dass ich
beziehungsweise wir beide hier drauf
sind von daher sind wir ein wenig
unwissend komme ich jetzt nicht in die
abkürzung gleich wäre freilich auch von
daher
es ist egal wo du jetzt bist weil ich
gleich auf tot bin ich bin da wo ich
überhaupt nichts weil ich mich einfach
umbringen komm ich jetzt
ich versuche noch ein bisschen was zu
reißen und dann auch schon wir zahlen
bekommt wenn jetzt irgendwo was zu essen
ist dann wäre es natürlich hammer aber
das wird willkommen seien irgendwie was
ich entschuldige mich für die
verhältnisse des lichtes ja ja die
sonics nicht sein hier ist nicht so was
zu essen wie man ihn hier länger als die
nacht überleben
und da hinten sind zombies ja toll super
hierzu crafting table bringt aber nichts
verstehe ich nicht also bisher muss ich
sagen genauso wie der seit auf dauer
recht langweilig kraft ich werde
teilweise einfach so zurückgebaut
irgendwohin laufe und hier muss ist doch
mal irgendwie was geben was ich mir hier
so rein pfeifen kann ja ist natürlich
auch klug da kann ja nicht erlaufen
mein gott ich blöd es ist so schlecht
gebaute mann kann ich einfach nicht mehr
laufen ja okay ich fahre jetzt gerade
ja dann bin ich gleich auch wenn ich
eigentlich ganz interessante sachen
bringen die man auch selber um so
warcraft the ground to his bekommen gar
nicht leben dazu
wenn man eine führung geäußert ich
glaube da kommt man nicht man braucht
diese manager scott präsident vor allem
heilen die auch nur ein halbes her ja
das ist richtig krass da kann man gar
nicht so lange überleben
es ist unglaublich oder man ist wirklich
so gut dass man die ganze zeit andere
leute tötet oder wir müssen das echt mal
so machen dass wir anderen sagen ja wir
sind freudig langeweile auf den darauf
das letzte mal ein bisschen aber ich
glaube im echten überleben wenn das so
sein
ich weiß echt okay gut du bist schon
wieder gespannt oder bis nach dem spawn
bist du hallo you you don't have
permission spawn mainz etwas nicht so
denn bis nach dadurch musste kurz
unterbrechen
ach so ich dachte schon wo warst du okay
ich bin wieder neu gesperrt und zwar
wohl beste sagt man seine koordinaten
ich muss kurz wieder ein
was da draußen ja ich bin auch gestorben
ich bin ungefähr bei 1500 da laufe ich
gerade in das sind ganz gute gut
merkbaren koordinator das ist gut da bin
ich auch ja ja 1500 1000 und 500
er ist also ich sehe hier so ein bisserl
in seinem haus dringt also ich bin grad
bei 1204 160 bei seinem weg den gehe ich
einfach mal lang wo bist du
ich glaube dieser weg kommt dann direkt
zu mir ich habe hier aber ein gegner ich
bis jetzt nicht auf dem lande das haben
wir verstanden uns haben wie greif ich
bestimmt nicht an
da könnte ich schön abschminken der
halle zu schön
warum sind jetzt so viele zombies auf
einmal wieder die nicht gehört haben
trotzdem also so ganz plötzlich zack
zack auf immer world zombies tm nicht
gehört versteht auch nicht besser ich
lauf rum
ich sehe ich sehe ein gegner das ist
länder mit das ist hier dass länder typ
ich versuchen auf den draufzugehen
der sommer in seinen dingens gucken sein
inventar dann kann ich den vielleicht
falschen nein hab ich gesehen scheiße
geehrt sein schwert so zur seite gezeigt
okay dann gehe ich das nicht drauf
oder ist natürlich jetzt blöd ist sicher
nichts der kommt hier gleich bestimmt an
und tötet mich ja ok erstellten da costa
lüthi tod coast road romero vor ich gehe
einfach mal hans griffig den mann hans
ruf in die richtung da hinten ja hier
steht sondern so ein pfeiler mit so ein
paar straßenschildern und so weiter ich
gehe einfach mal die straße lang zu
diesem hand liegen was mit hunting heißt
natürlich jagen das heißt ich glaube da
hinten sind ein paar interessante sachen
aber das erste was ich in aller erster
linie brauche ist was zu essen
ich glaube ich bleib angegeben ich will
hunger games noch ein bisschen
spannender aber so mal für zwischendurch
so als geist zum wie zombies bereit
ich bin jetzt wieder - 2500 für sie
zwischendurch ist das glaube ich schon
ganz interessant ganz wichtig dass man
sieht das ist auch andere alternativen
zu angeln die langweiliger sind keiner
von denen hat mich entdeckt dass er sehr
komisch oder hinten ist der typ wieder
der chip sei schuld die hunger games
gespielt mit den mit vielen gegnern
ja ich habe schon auch schon mehrere
videos davon hoogland recht auf so
amerikanischen server mit 40 anderen
leuten und 250 jahr 115 der zuviel
wusste ich doch dass du bist nicht mein
typ lässt mich in ruhe das ist cool so
ich träume und sterbe und scheunen und
ställe und scheunen sterbe
und ich habe aber es hakt sowas von habe
ich tolle sachen
okay sie immer ein kleines see ein
kleines de ein kleiner tümpel oder so
bin ich jetzt bin ich gespannt
sag mal direkt gute sachen also da
liegen sie einmal koordinaten ich bin
jetzt bei 2.300 ok kommission kommt zu
1000 irgendwas 2000 1000 irgendwas ich
bin gerade bei 1100 dessen gegner
das kann man nur mit einer potro kaputt
machen
man kann die melone nur mit einer wurden
hohe kaputt machen
es sind dass ich etwas zu essen ist es
gut wenn ein bisschen rosarotes
farbpulver wie es in riesigen stadt oder
sowas kommt stirbt doch alter ist sagt
so was von mir das ist schrecklich
ja ich hab grad einen getötet aber jetzt
kommt ihr auf einmal trainieren
und jetzt ist es jetzt hab ich in grafik
back und alles ist total dunkel
natürlich jetzt auch interessant und
jetzt habe ich die ganze stadt ist ein
werk das ist ja das bin ich recht gut
jeden moment wenn ich das schaffen
nein ich hatte richtig gute sachen
irgendwie die lage alle rum
ach man bisher muss ich sagen es ist
nervenaufreibend dieses spiel ist
langweilig langweilig besser ganz kurz
antesten so ich würde sagen wir machen
zwei papst davon
dann nehmen wir von vier minuten auf an
sich war das spiel war einfach
langweilig und zu hart finde ich sechs
sekunden warten jetzt kann ich da wieder
drauf ich bin drauf rein 6 poncet sag
mal bist du ich bin bei - 2360 ganz vorn
ist bin ich gut dann will ich sagen
jetzt einfach noch ein bisschen rum
versuche ich noch ein bisschen was zu
zeigen
immer wenn ihr selber mal testen wollt
die die webseite in den fußnoten mega
lag server reporting and second sich der
inzeller
in fünf sekunden ja torlos endet gut
okay dann würde ich sagen beenden wir
hiermit diese interessante langweilige
serie von sälen des und kleines special
zu meinen set was ist dein fazit scheiße
bei mir würde verriet ich möchte ich so
treffe ich möchte einfach mal sein
für spieler die ein hartes survival
zombie game suchen und zwar kostenlose
variante dann könnt ihr gerne auf den
server draufgehen aber für mich ist das
nichts weil wenn man das richtig spielen
würde dann müsste man glaube ich immens
lang einfach nur rumlaufen als nieten
damit an die zombies nicht sehen und
dann sich irgendwelche sachen zusammen
suchen und dann ist man auch schon
wieder tot wenn das essen runter ist wie
in den ravels kann man nicht länger als
eine halbe stunde spielen finde ich ja
ich denke mal wenn man das hatte auch
wirklich kennt dann ist das bestimmt
spannend aber dafür müsste man sich
natürlich erstmal ein paar infos holen
ein paar videos gucken oder sowas
ich glaube noch an weiteren auf wo was
liegt wo kisten sind und so könnte es
vielleicht entspannen sollen aber so
meinen wir haben uns bisher auf dem
server auch nur die diese dinge nciht
durchgelesen diese ganzen schilder aber
es gibt ja noch einen website mindset
irgendwas heißt das einfach mal googlen
und dort stehen ganz ganz viele weitere
infos zu der map ist ob des eher noch
ein bild von der map oder so ein paar
sachen paar tipps also wenn man das
wirklich gut spielen will und paar tipps
und grundlegende fakten haben will dann
einfach die seite besuchen und dann
wisst ihr da mehr weil wir konnten euch
jetzt auch nicht viel dazu sagen das ist
das zweite mal dass sich auf dem server
bin beim erstmalig einfach ganz kurz
vorbeigeschaut und dann würde ich
eigentlich auch schon sagen was das mit
diesem special zusammen war dabei
minecraft expert.de und hallo minecraft
expert.de hallo